[Musique]
certaines personnes pensent que si on
répète les mêmes d'histoire a si souvent
elles deviennent réelles
[Musique]
elles font de nous ce que nous sommes
et ça ça fait peur
tu veux voir une maison d
des enfants disparus alors ils ont
condamné la maison
c'est bon on l'a vu on va y aller
maintenant
ça sent la poule mouillée
qu'est ce que c'est un recueil
d'histoires effrayante
quand on a une histoire
qu'est ce qui se passe le mieux disparu
dans le livre le personnage sap et tony
c'est forcément une coïncidence non et
c'est ce qui se passait dans le livre se
passait aussi dans la vraie vie au guide
la tuer dans la prochaine histoire à la
rochelle
non
j'ai peur qu'on ait déclenché quelque
chose
ce livre à vous n'auriez pas dû le
prendre
me collard est
voir les bras
livre de sarah bellows ces histoires
s'écrivent tout seul et ensuite elles
deviennent réelles
[Musique]
je viens pour notre sujet